[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi à 15
mars
ils ne font pas les unes des journaux
n'occupent pas les antennes de télé ou
des radios et pourtant eux aussi font
campagne pour l'élection présidentielle
nous avons suivi des militants de lutte
ouvrière dans les yvelines où la
difficulté aussi de faire campagne pour
un petit parti dans un département
largement habitués à voter à droite une
leçon de courage et d'abnégation aussi
dans ce journal avec la rencontre de
samuel mari un jeune homme lourdement
handicapé depuis ses 20 ans et qui se
lance à la conquête du monde avec sa
camionnette ils étaient ils hier à
vélizy villacoublay pour présenter son
projet ils n'ont pas à 10 ans mes
photographies déjà des portraits comme
des vrais professionnels à coignières
dans le cadre d'un atelier pédagogique
des élèves de cm1 travailler avec un
photographe
objectif leur faire découvrir un univers
méconnu et des les plus timides d'entre
eux se dirige-t-on vers un nouveau et
diesel guettent après volkswagen cette
fois ci c'est renault qui est dans la
ligne de mire des autorités le groupe
français aurait selon la direction de la
répression des fraudes
installer un dispositif faussant les
tests anti pollution l'investigation
cible de voitures phares de la marque au
losange la capture et la clio iv aussi
la voiture la plus vendue en france la
société dément de son côté avoir
enfreint les règles ce qui n'a pas
empêché son action de chuter en bourse
aujourd'hui elle investigations se
poursuivent et les polémiques touche
aussi cette folle campagne
présidentielle ensemble des parties des
principaux partis est concerné mais
qu'en est il alors des petits candidats
difficile pour eux de faire campagne
dans cette drôle d'ambiance c'est ce que
nous avons pu vérifier avec des
militants de lutte ouvrière qui
soutiennent nathalie arthaud ils étaient
présents devant la gare de versailles
chantiers il ya quelques jours
reportage de nicolas landry
entendre les exigences du monde du
travail rencontre organisée hier
[Musique]
travailleurs une campagne de terrain
essentiel pour les militants derrière
nathalie arthaud avec une présence
médiatique faible la candidate de lutte
ouvrière axe sa stratégie en allant à la
rencontre des citoyens ont fait la
campagne telle qu'on la conçoit c'est à
dire à la rencontre des gens à la fois
devant les gares sur les marchés comme
mon come on a commencé à faire comme on
fait tout le temps parce que de toute
façon les petits candidats on n'a pas
tellement le choix de faire cette
campagne proche de la population
si certains passants ne prête pas
attention tracts d'autres s'arrêtent et
échanges avec les militants en gros je
suis convaincu qu il faut comme vous le
faites convaincre le peuple d'abord et
pas prendre le peuple et lui dire tu es
toi c'est notre système tu acceptes
c'est bien de vendre du rêve au conte
citoyen français
mais d'un autre côté c'est aussi bien
d'agir de la sorte c'est à dire le dire
les choses c'est une chose mais avec des
actes c'est encore mieux
j'ai senti qu'ils avaient une discussion
possible
sur sur son programme en fait les signes
de sa et comme chou c'est assez rare
finalement parce que là en ce moment
distribuer beaucoup de trac mais sans
forcément pas expliqué débattre en fait
coeur de l'électorat de lutte ouvrière
les travailleurs avec une mesure phare
pour les séduire l'interdiction du
licenciement
politique toujours avec thierry mandon
le secrétaire d'état chargé de
l'enseignement supérieur qui s'est rendu
hier à l'institut d'études politiques de
saint germain en laye une visite qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre d'une tournée
nationale sur les innovations
pédagogiques lieu pays yvelinois le
dixième du nom souffre pour le moment
d'un manque de reconnaissance un
problème sur lequel souhaite agir
thierry mandon écoutez le au micro de
nos confrères d'yveline première et je
vais associés s'ils le souhaitent
l'établissement de sciences po saint
germain à une la main de la principale
manifestation qu'organise le ministère
qui s'appelle le ministère ont ouvert la
nuit au ministère l'année prochaine
en sorte que les étudiants de
l'établissement s'ils le souhaitent
soient un peu les guides médiateur de
cette soirée là et puis plus
généralement réfléchir aux besoins de
consolidation en termes de postes
l'année prochaine corade dont on aura
besoin cet établissement dans le reste
de l'actualité une histoire et un projet
pas comme les autres ceux de samuel
marie tétraplégique depuis qu'il a 20
ans ce passionné de voyages veut à
travers son opération sam qui roule
faire le tour du monde avec sa
camionnette
parrainée par philippe positive hors jo
l'homme qui a inspiré le film
intouchables
il était hier au crm à vélizy
villacoublay pour présenter son projet
osman vanguard est devenu tétraplégique
à l'âge de 20 ans se mêlent mari n'a
jamais perdu son goût pour les voyages
et c'est un défi hors du commun qu'il
souhaite relever
en effet avec son opération ça me fait
rouler il souhaite traverser les états
unis l'europe et l'asie
et pour réaliser son rêve il s'entraîne
depuis deux ans je suis tous les jours
sur mon petit vélo pour pouvoir se
développer au niveau musculaire avec le
corry jane parce que ces décors un petit
peu fragile la table et c'est pour ça
que les personnes avant moi l'ont pas
fait parce que c'est un petit peu
compliqué à mettre en place et je vais
être je vais être aidé par un kiné à
distance aussi qui m'aidera aussi sur
les sur certaines douleurs et tout ça
pour nous accompagner
donc voilà il ya un kiné qui passe cette
fois par par semaine chez moi qui
m'aident aussi pour pour ça il ya muscu
renforcement des vélos et je fais pas
mal de sport autour pour traverser ces
seize pays samuel sera au volant d'une
camionnette d'une valeur de 130 mille
euros qui pourra répondre à tous ces
besoins et son projet intéresse lambert
traîneau race le pdg de la start-up
giraud lift
c'est un soutien dans un premier temps
de dire est logistique c'était de
réseaux partage de réseaux de connexion
et puis à terme lorsque nos
nos deux start-up se rejoignent rond et
pourquoi pas fournir un giro livre pour
que pour ses prochaines aventures et en
fait ça mais la vitrine de ces personnes
l'objectif c'est de rendre le giro
livres adaptés à tous types de handicaps
et donc est donc d'arriver à terme à
permettre à une personne tétraplégique
comme samuel de pouvoir utiliser notre
nouveau fauteuil roulant pour mener à
bien son pari sam a besoin de 300000
euros il est actuellement à la recherche
de sponsors
il participera prochainement au salon du
tourisme qui se déroule du 16 au 19 mars
à porte de versailles à paris
dans la même thématique se chiffrent en
france seuls 7% des jeunes scolarisés en
situation de handicap accèdent aux
études supérieures et c'est pour faire
évoluer cette situation que le concours
tous en scène est organisé depuis
plusieurs années pour l'occasion des
étudiants sont invités à créer des
vidéos de 2 à 3 minutes pour dévoiler
leur regard sur le handicap
une équipe d' hec de jouy-en-josas
participe à la cinquième édition du
concours ils ont monté une comédie
musicale
rencontre avec camille lambert cette
pièce l'association dax tedj la
travaille depuis janvier sont 28
danseurs chanteurs et musiciens à créer
leur comédie musicale c'est pas
seulement de jouer mais c'est aussi de
penser les arrangements donc on écoute
des chansons qui sont pas du tout écrite
pour notre formation pour nos
instruments et nous on doit tout
réécoutez trotoux retranscrire noël et
c'est ça qui est vraiment difficile qui
prend beaucoup de temps mais qui est
aussi très intéressant dans notre
travail
une création artistique et solidaire en
mai elle sera jouée devant des enfants
atteints de cancer et de handicap qu'on
est venu avec l'idée de
qui est un partenariat avec deux
associations d'achat c'est donc rêve
d'enfance et cherop qui soutiennent la
cause d'enfants atteints par le cancer
et souhaite représentation là sera
suivie d'ateliers de musique de danse et
de chant le jour suivant sur le campus
donc avec l'idée de bas de leur
transmettre notre passion pour
promouvoir ce projet les étudiants
participent au concours tous en scène
dans une vidéo ils ont expliqué leurs
objectifs le prix ce serait en fait ce
serait pour justement ne pas ne pas leur
faire payer les places parce que enfin
ça fait partie du projet et voilà de
devoir ouvrir des balcons au comédia
qu'ils théâtre splendide
ça nous coûte aussi et le prix nous
permettrait justement de pouvoir
rembourser ces coups là ça serait une
chance formidable de pouvoir mener ce
projet comme on veut et pouvoir offrir à
ses enfants ce qu'on voudrait
la pièce parle d'un jeune homme aux
goudes aventure une épopée sur le destin
arrivera-t-elle à transporter le jury et
réponse à la cérémonie de remise des
prix le 30 mars la direction coignières
à présent où des élèves de l'école
élémentaire marcel pagnol suivent depuis
plusieurs semaines des cours
pédagogiques axés autour du portrait ils
reçoivent notamment les conseils d'un
photographe professionnel pour assurer
une séance de shooting
leur travail sera ensuite exposé en
pleine ville reportage de patrick
jacques de dixmude
alors passez vous ici juste ici
là comme ça timothée n'a que 9 ans mais
donne déjà l'impression d'être un
habitué des studios un appareil autour
du cou qui fait presque la taille de son
visage le jeune apprenti shoot son
modèle du jour un fauconnier dont ils
photographient le portrait est
maintenant on résout l'oiseau hockey
d'anglais te regarde bien sûr les
conseils de frédéric grah professionnel
reconnu et des cours et les élèves de
cm1 prennent en charge eux mêmes la
séance apprentissage express dans un
univers méconnu
on a appris tout ce que tout ce qu'il y
avait dans un studio tout ce que tout ce
qu'on devait faire sur l'appareil photo
les objets que les objets qu'on devait
utiliser dans un studio
j'avais pris la boîte à lumière en
association avec les itinéraires
poétique de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ces ateliers pédagogiques est allé sur
plusieurs semaines permettent également
aux plus jeunes de travailler sur la
découverte de l'autre et le partage
d'expériences des éléments qui peuvent
aider certains élèves
les enfants sont très contents de
rentrer dans un projet commun ils
peuvent aussi se démarquer sur autre
chose que le travail écrit et justement
pour les enfants très timide ça leur
fait aussi du bien de pouvoir parler de
pouvoir justement essayer de ne pas être
dans le carcan de la classe elle les
portraits des élèves seront exposées
dans les rues de poignard à partir de la
fin du mois de mai envie d'un moment de
détente ou simplement de tester votre
niveau d'orthographe l'association
lecture et dialogues de plaisir propos
chaque année des dictées ouverte à tous
mauvais élèves ou as de la conjugaison
l'une d'entre elles était organisé il ya
quelques jours nicolas landry et anne
laure l'anguille traumatismes de
l'enfance pour certains la dictée
constitue un loisir pour d'autres comme
ici à plaisir ou une vingtaine
d'amoureux de la langue se prêtent au
jeu ou plutôt devrait-on dire à la
torture à l'embl naturel virgule
l'orthographe c'est amusant quand on est
adulte c'est peut-être temps drôle quand
on est élève mais quand on devient
adulte ben c'est un défi qu'on peut se
donner et il
a pu cette angoisse de la faute qu'on a
eu ou le fait d'être jugé en ce juge toi
même avec les revenus mais prenez garde
à ne pas relâcher l'attention une dictée
comporte toujours des pièges comme si
cet apophtegme absolue apophtegme saas
explique comment bien alors j'ai écrit à
p o
pht e g m
bonne réponse l'association lecture et
dialogues qui organise cet événement
veut promouvoir l'enrichissement est
l'expression personnelle mais une dictée
c'est aussi un voyage à travers
l'histoire d'une fille en même temps
cette moment on peut aussi dans ce type
d'exercice renouer avec ce qu'est
l'histoire de la langue et parfois
l'histoire tout court l'évolution des
baux concentrer le temps de la dictée
les participants sortent ravis de
l'épreuve
j'adore cet exercice j'adore cet
exercice j'avais fait celle de l'année
dernière et donc du coup je me suis
relancé à nouveau l'objectif de départ
était de réaliser un score au moins
équivalent à celui de l'an passé aux jo
j'étais légèrement au-dessus de la
moyenne
selon un récent sondage les français
restent très attachés à leur langue mais
garde un mauvais souvenir des dictées à
l'école un ressenti que l'association
espère effacer en mobilisant plus de
participants l'an prochain
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal tous
nos reportages sont à retrouver en
replay sur notre site internet et les
fils sont 18 points comme ou
l'application tv fils bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]